hoje eu vim pra conversar um pouquinho
com vocês é exatamente sobre algumas
descobertas que eu fiz ao longo da minha
vida
ainda só um pouco nova mas acho que
alguma coisa já aprendi por aí
a primeira delas que eu acho muito
bacana é a gente se dá conta o quanto as
pessoas que estão ao nosso redor elas
são influentes
desde o meu pai minha mãe que foi o meu
modelo até meus amigos ou aquelas
pessoas que um dia eu classifiquei como
bacanas
foram pessoas que tinham influência acho
que durante algum tempo a minha missão
de vida foi realmente convencer a minha
mãe que ela era a pessoa mais sortuda do
mundo
com isso eu acabava fazendo pensando e
sentindo muitas coisas em função dos
outros e não em função de mim
com o tempo isso começou a me incomodar
um pouquinho porque eu me dei conta que
na verdade o que eu tinha uma enorme
dificuldade de dizer não de fazer
exatamente o que eu queria
e justamente por repensar nessa questão
por reformular e isso que eu venho
dividir esse pensamento com vocês aqui
no texas
a primeira coisa que a gente precisa se
dar conta que a coisa mais honesta que a
gente pode fazer com a gente é dizer não
além de ser algo extremamente honesto é
uma prova de maturidade é a prova que a
gente realmente sabe se posicionar é a
prova que a gente pode escolher
exatamente o que a gente quer é a prova
que dizer sim ou não são duas coisas
extremamente naturais
eu gosto de dizer também que a gente só
consegue escolher e dizer não e se guiar
verdadeiramente por aquilo que a gente
quer quando a gente diminui um pouquinho
os ruídos e escuta o que a gente chama
de voz interior
essa voz interior eu costumo dizer que
são os nossos valores são as nossas
vontades e ela que vai dizer para vocês
o caminho que vocês devem trilhar sem
julgamentos
o julgamento gente na verdade é uma
coisa super arcaica que parece que
colocaram na nossa vida ea gente se
agarra até hoje
o julgamento é o certo eo errado do
outro não é o de vocês não seguirem por
ele
uma coisa que a gente tem que pensar
também é que às vezes é difícil se
posicionar ainda mais na sociedade
moderna que a gente tem hoje que a gente
tem tantas opções e tantas coisas pra
fazer que parece que dizer não a gente
vai estar sempre vamos de alguma coisa a
gente vai estar deixando de viver ou de
certa forma a gente vai estar de câmbio
de alguma possibilidade
na verdade pode até soar um pouco
egoísta a gente dizer não tenho certeza
não é nada egoísta dizer não
cada vez que vocês dizem não vocês
conseguem se aproximar daquilo que é
genuíno pra vocês daquilo que vocês
exatamente querem claro gente que isso
pressupõe que vocês pensem um pouquinho
quais são os valores que vocês têm os
caminhos que vocês querem trilhar e
principalmente qual é a busca qual é o
propósito de vocês aqui o que vocês
vieram fazer independente dos outros e
eu gosto de dizer também que a vida
extremamente gentil com quem se
posiciona a vida gosta de quem toma
decisões
só assim a vida pode realmente devolver
aquilo que vocês procuram não é no
talvez não é em cima do muro e sim no
momento que vocês tomam uma decisão que
vocês realmente tem as rédeas da vida de
vocês
eu costumo dizer que as pessoas que
sabem se posicionar elas tendem a ser
mais felizes do que aquelas que ainda
não sabem muito bem o que fazer ou
seguiam pelo outro
parem de procurar fora lá não existe
nada tudo que existe está dentro de
vocês
e aí que residem as possibilidades que
vocês têm de se transformarem escolherem
exatamente o que vocês querem sem tirar
nem cor isso gente pode ser que não seja
algo muito fácil de se fazer um primeiro
momento confesso para vocês que eu tive
muita dificuldade
mas eu também acredito que a gente pode
mudar a partir de um treino ou de
atitudes extremamente simples para se
fazer no dia a dia
a primeira delas que deixaria de dica
pra vocês é vocês saberem exatamente
onde vocês querem chegar
reserve um tempo para pensar nisso que é
tão simples
vocês devem lembrar do gato da alice ele
é bastante famoso e tem a frase ou diz
no filme enfim quem não sabe onde cair
qualquer caminho serve
observe no dia a dia de vocês se vocês
não estão indo pra qualquer caminho
pensa em quais são as prioridades
seguirem por elas
outra questão que a gente também pode
pensar é sejam autênticos e seu tente
com gente a coisa mais simples do mundo
quando a gente quer dizer não a gente
diz não e é simples assim mesmo sem
muito drama sem muita explicação apenas
digão aquilo que deve ser dito
outra questão que a gente também pode
olhar juntos é a questão do treino a
primeira vez que eu me dei conta disso e
que me propus a dizer não pra alguma
coisa eu confesso que eu morri de medo
como eu nunca tinha feito aquilo dizer o
primeiro não era algo apavorante
eu acho que demorei uns 45 dias até a
coragem necessária para chegar lá e
dizer não pra alguma coisa que eu
realmente queria dizer não eu fiz gente
e eu confesso para vocês que ninguém
morreu que está todo mundo bem ea vida
segue
tenham a coragem de fazer o que deve ser
feito que é dizer não quando a gente
quer dizer não da forma mais autêntica
possível
a outra questão que tem é que quando a
gente diz não a gente está se abrindo
para o mundo de uma forma muito simples
a gente explora as possibilidades quando
a gente trilha novos caminhos
tentem fazer diferente saiam do trivial
saiam do feijão e do arroz de todo dia
explore digam não quando deve ser dito
não de forma muito breve para a gente
finalizar
quem diria pra vocês que cada vez que
vocês dizem não o assumem alguma
possibilidade na vida de vocês vocês
também estão num processo de crescimento
e de amadurecimento
a vida só anda quando a gente toma as
decisões que devem ser tomadas e vai com
coragem para os rumos que a gente
decidiu fazer
não tenham medo de dizer não é dizer não
ou dizer sim apesar de coisas diferentes
enfim levarem para caminhos diferentes
são questões extremamente naturais
o recado geral de hoje é tomem as rédeas
da vida de vocês
ninguém vai fazer por vocês ninguém vai
decidir
e isso é uma escolha extremamente
individual façam sem medo
digão não e sejam felizes muito obrigada
gente